I think 300 teams started the
competition they ended up about ten
final it's one of the teams started
right here singing their diversity I
have one of their little torta types of
what they call the the the scanner D
Scout it was not one of the winners and
they they went through early clinical
trials crowdfunder this but it's a the
idea of a medical tricorder something
you could hold to your forehead pull
down your temperature your heart rate
your oxygen saturation talk to your
smartphone and bed it without emotional
intelligence this company's going on to
do some other projects but even the
teams that sort of don't win have helped
advanced medical science and this is an
example of convergent technologies the
technologies here that can measure blood
oxygenation or help calculate blood
pressure or pick up temperature may have
cost ten thousand dollars twenty years
ago but I've gotten cheaper and Shiva
fide and app' fide and with Bluetooth
connectivity can now be something you
could manufacture and put in your pocket
for under a hundred dollars so I think
and the winning team for the Trekker
XPrize was started by a emergency
medicine doctor and his engineering
family so you get people thinking out of
the box and taking technologies that
haven't been mashed together and
applying a new lens and I think we'll
have technologies like this in our
pockets who are connected to our
smartphones the next few years so that
you'll use this to do stage your
medicine to pick up that you have a you
know tract infection and you get it
treated early or to diagnose that
pneumonia or pick up signs of any number
of elements and then to manage a disease